so wrong it's so wrong i'm gonna tell
you right now i've never talked about
this uh uh [ __ ]
i like to be like a runaway slave okay
no
[ __ ] oh my god
i like to play like a runaway slave okay
a disobedient slave with a white woman
so tell me like what you say yes man
i'm so sorry
i've it's just two it's it's two of them
like it's like me getting whooped
right you get whooped it's like like i
play like you whip it but most of them
don't want to play like that this is
this
white woman goes along with this they
don't want to play like that they don't
work this is my fault that's like
listen you're going to act like your
masters
your master's
wife
and i'm the one and i just got whooped
by myself
but the whole time you've been really
you know you've been like me eyeballing
me oh this sounds like something freaky
porn right this some freaky [ __ ] and
then i'm gonna i'm gonna come all sweaty
right just finished getting whooped and
you're gonna say no billy joe no no
nasties not gonna like it he's not
hmm
[Laughter]
i really tried
i really tried i really tried not to
kink shame and [ __ ] but oh my lie
oh my god
all right well okay
oh and then he got dragged this
[ __ ] got dragged too for what he
said okay i'm gonna tell you this this
will happen when a man open up that's
one okay we're past that we're past that
we are past that that being said
not everything needs to be opened up
okay you can keep that [ __ ] for you all
right that was not some [ __ ] where you
have to feel vulnerable about some
no that's not what we're talking about
yo rappers really be going in on these
podcasts and exposing themselves yes you
did that to yourself it's like we ever
it would have cost you
zero dollars
zero dollars to not say that [ __ ]
it would have cost you zero duckets to
go
and talk about that [ __ ] like that now
you look like a damn fool yes you could
express yourself mm-hmm live your life
boo-boo
but you didn't need to that was not a
need that was not you in distress needed
to talk about some deep [ __ ] that was no
you
and now people are going to say what
they're going to say i mean yo is it
just me
or a rapper is always sharing idea into
really weird stuff
yeah you find out a lot of these rappers
they can say a lot of stuff they can say
a bunch of anti-gay all this other stuff
find out they're into trying to happen
or like you don't mean they're like or
trade like don't don't don't don't play
but they know behind closed doors oh you
want they transition
but i just find it fun that some of
these guys who have been like outed have
like the most
anti-lgbtq students when they talk about
stuff but
go ahead that might be one of the
reasons
so the question is
is this stuff much much more common than
we think or or here's the other
hypothetical the kind of people who get
to hyper successful situations are the
kind of people who have extreme
proclivities
both both okay both and i think it's
weird i told you i got a bit on that hip
hop is the most
homophobic and gayest [ __ ] ever that's
what [ __ ] yeah that's your [ __ ] right
there
these [ __ ] you [ __ ] with do you even
hear yourself sometimes
how can you be so homophobic it's all
about you that's my [ __ ] that's who i
[ __ ] with
huh um you know that's that song
ultimate by denzel curry that's where
you hear we whit them up like a canteen
you always talk about getting people wet
that's in that song in one of them
that's one example about what that [ __ ]
is when they say that
hey yo
bing bong hey yo
yeah you wet them up is
but maybe it's because it's from a weird
part of some [ __ ] like that when you get
to when you get to
a certain status
you get the liberty or you get to enjoy
certain things yeah i guess right yeah
but yes here's the thing with this one
specifically yeah do what you want to do
but there was something about the
details that were a little bit
disturbing considering the racial
context that exists in america these
things don't happen in a vacuum we talk
about legendary king positive whatever i
can assure you this same fantasy doesn't
exist in a lot of other cultures or a
lot of it it exists within the culture
that it existed does it exists within
like the the area that it is why because
of the complex between black men and
white women right so that's where this
is born in so i'm not saying there's an
issue with the kick itself what i'm
saying is the kink is generally in this
kind of scenario i feel like it's a
reflection of your own internal racial
issues it's possible
man man man i went for the
talks about that podcast that i have on
sexuality and for the patreon we went in
attention
a mistress
right so she makes us a tour of the
dungeon and at some point she's like
yeah so we tie people on that cross and
preach would you like to try i'm like
[ __ ] you ain't tying nobody
you ain't putting handcuffs on no
body blood you're not doing it my guy
i'm not the one bro
okay well how about a finger in the bump
this nigga's like never
no but that no you're not tying me
you're not whipping me you're not
no
because because of the context because
of the context and because you know
maybe i got a little bit traumatized
when i was a kid nobody is handcuffing
me yeah okay putting end cover i don't
care if they're in plastic i'm breaking
them shits yeah all right i'm breaking
free yeah here houdini up in this all
right yeah uh so yeah
but there's some people that that they
[ __ ] but the racial component to the to
the fantasies was fascinating because
you know it pays into the racial
politics that's the reason why i don't
get whoop yeah but you know what i mean
so that's what makes me look at him
funny you know what i'm saying like for
him
for that to be a get off i think it
reflects something deep he knows what
he's doing yeah
like if i was getting with a white woman
for example and she was trying to tell
me that's her fantasy like she want to
tie me up and then say the n word a
bunch of time i would look at her crazy
i would still do it but i would look at
her crazy
but i'm too vanilla for all this stuff
for me it's just too weird like i just
can't be bothered i can't be bothered
with all this
nipple clamps and [ __ ] no no no getting
walk on your balls and [ __ ] no no no no
no none of that stuff getting thrown up
on your dick
like it just doesn't appeal to me like
from a role play standpoint like i've
had the whole girl suggest like the cops
and robbers thing i was like we're not
doing that that's weird that's weird
that's weird like you want to be like
put on some diapers and then take a
a pacifier and then get spanked on your
bum like
listen do what you want to do but i'ma
look at you a little crazy that's all
sorry
no that's weird there's there's people
that do that the whole
weekend and so
here's the thing i know [ __ ]
that cater to them okay here's the thing
right wild stories
i think sex positivity is a good thing i
think accepting folks for a lot of their
sexual proclivities making things more
accessible and starting the roofs of the
taboo i think it's good but we can also
agree that everything has its extremes
and that not everything should be
included in that okay i actually have
friends who work in that industry who
tell me like the race place stuff is
really weird and they don't touch that
for a reason yeah yeah
yeah and i'm like why not it's like it's
gonna stick pop's like there's something
weird going on and even they won't touch
that yeah i know that yeah absolutely i
know so you're a hundred on that they're
like um yeah i'd rather not yeah you
could go see someone else that does it
rough i'm not gonna but yeah yeah
absolutely it's dudes out here telling
on themselves for no reason
it happens a lot didn't it yeah
so again sometimes i take a [ __ ] and
then i smear it on my face and sniff it
ooh sex pop that's weird
do do what you do but
don't do that on our podcast
weirdly what you just said right now
made sense i know i don't know you
actually said it lied the other day it
really threw me off in a recent video
you said something like uh
if you got what you got but you didn't
get what you got you got what you
deserved [ __ ] don't no i just made it up
don't agree
i just made it up right now
but it sounds like something i'm saying
yeah you did that
and i'm in the video still thinking and
i rewatched the video and i'm like i
don't know what this is saying
but you said it was something you make
assistant bro
you got to try doing it right bro
listen you have the thing is
you don't have to mean what you say you
have to feel it
that made sense
but that's exactly it
you don't do
you don't do what you got you got what
you deserve i don't know
once it said it said it i set it free
it's out there
no i can't let it go because we need to
get to the bottom of this because i
don't think anybody knows
but i i need to know
what you didn't think you got
you didn't deserve it
no because if you get like you got it
what you thought you did you know i mean
if you get
what you didn't you didn't got
then you deserve it because you tested
[ __ ]
and then you got an answer oh my god and
that real you didn't think you'd get
this but you got it if you get
you anything you got
you deserve what you got yeah
so
enjoy your becky slave master have a
good day
what's billy joel
reference from a movie uh billy joe is
the singer of green day
when i come around